vous êtes passionné par les nouvelles
technologies vous rêvez créer votre
start up dans rejoindre une nous avons
créé ce cours pour l'e book en fait
massive online open quand si ce sont des
cours massif en ligne ouvert au public
le plus large possible et présentant les
sujets extrême des sujets extrêmement
divers nous avons un cours spécifique
alix sur la création d'entreprises
innovantes mais nous avons décidé en
lien avec hec de créer un cours sur
création et développement d'une
entreprise technologique avec le
développement des moûts qu il nous a
semblé utile d'explorer ces nouveaux
termites héritière de transmission du
savoir avec ces nouveaux dispositifs qui
ne consiste pas simplement à donner des
cours en ligne mais également à créer
une interaction de plusieurs milliers de
personnes sur des forums de discussion
et donc pour nous le lancement de ce
mook était une sorte d' initiatives de
recherche développement pour tester
d'avoir un échange avec avec des publics
avec lesquels on échange et pas
naturellement ce qui nous a amené à
lancer ce mook qui à ce jour a totalisé
plus de dix mille cinq cents inscrits
venant de 140 pays différents avec donc
la structure traditionnelle d'un book à
savoir des sessions vidéo est allé sur
sur cinq semaines à raison d'une heure
de vidéo tous les mois et toute une
série de des changes sur un forum des
quiz
évidemment en l'espace de cinq heures
cumulées de vidéos
on ne se substitue pas à une formation à
hec ou à polytechnique ou un master in
business administration
mais on fait passer des messages
essentiels et on est le catalyseur d'une
discussion stratégique
il s'agit de mettre à disposition du
plateau de saclay ses contenus qui sont
déjà portée non seulement par des
enseignants des experts et des
entrepreneurs de x mais par des
entrepreneurs et des experts issus de
l'ensemble de l'université plateau de
saclay et d'emblée dans la structuration
de ce mook notre intention a été
d'ouvrir cela pour devenir un des outils
de référence en matière de
sensibilisation à la création
d'entreprises innovantes et à la
création d'entreprises technologiques en
particulier